where do you in these possible
explanations to the fermi paradox why
haven't we contacted aliens
do you land on well
i think the most straightforward
explanation is that there aren't any
now
there are many other explanations too so
i you can't be dogmatic about things
that are just sort of gut feel
but
you know one of my favorite
twilight zone episodes i don't ever saw
this one where
this alien civilization finally comes to
planet earth and and gives us this book
that they really want us to to have and
to hold and it's in this foreign you
know language you don't understand the
cryptographers they desperately try to
decipher it as humans are going to visit
this other alien planet and they're all
sending back postcards how wonderful it
is and so forth and they they finally
they decipher the title it's to serve
man and everyone's so thrilled oh
they're here to service it all makes
sense and then just as one of the final
cryptographers is going on to the alien
ship
his his helper runs and says i've
deciphered the rest of the book to serve
man it's a cookbook you know so
you know
so yeah is that is that
a possibility sure you know and and so
could they be watching us and just sort
of waiting for us to uh get to
a mature enough
level
i don't know it strikes me well you know
i think it'd be better to have this
conversation after the james webb
telescope i mean i do think that
um if we look at the atmospheres
of many planets i mean there's now an
estimate now that there's on order of
one planet per star on average so we've
long known that you know the galaxy
hundreds of billions of stars numbers of
galaxies hundreds of billions of
galaxies so we're talking about hundreds
of billions of hundreds of billions of
planets oh my you know and if we start
to survey some of these planets and one
after the other after the other we just
sort of find
no evidence for
any of the biological markers it could
be of course maybe life takes a
radically different form it'd be hard to
know that but i think you know that
would at least give us some insight on
the life question but i just don't see
how we get insight on the civilization
or consciousness question without you
know the direct connection and and it
strikes me that if consciousness is
ubiquitous
let's say life is i'm willing to grant
that if consciousness is also ubiquitous
then i don't understand
why they haven't been here or why there
hasn't been separate decisions because
presumably
they should be much further ahead of us
how unlikely would it be that we're like
of all consciousness in the universe
we're the most advanced that would be
such a special
place for human beings that it's hard
for me to grant that as a likely
possibility rather i think we're kind of
running the mill
and there are many who are far more
advanced than us and i don't think that
they
would expend the energy to hide
themselves
so i don't think they care enough and so
i see that's actually what i i believe
that there's a
very large number of civilizations that
are far more advanced than us
but my sense is that humans are
exceptionally limited both in our direct
sensory capabilities and our physics
our tools
of sensing that just like with the
string theory and the multiple
dimensions we're just not
like it's like i honestly believe there
could be stuff in front of our nose that
we're just not seeing
what because we're too dumb too
uh too much hubris
and i mean it's a bunch of stuff and too
ignorant as the
to to the fabric of reality all of those
things yeah we're young
yeah in terms of intelligence but i
guess what i'd say is like i'm on board
with all of that as a real possibility
but then
it does strike me that
we are sufficiently
able to observe
the unit look we can look back to
you know
a fraction of the duration
from here to just a fraction is left
that we are unable to see
so however young we are
we have been able to sort of pierce the
universe and it just strikes me that
there would be some signature but maybe
maybe that that's coming but but look
having said that i do
look i i certainly note the fact that
it's rare that i stooped down
while walking in manhattan and sort of
dig up some ants in the bushes on the
side of the street and talk to the ants
right because it's just not interesting
to me so if we're like the ants on the
cosmological landscape then yeah i can
imagine that the super advanced aliens
would be like
like whoever you know but but i feel
like we're sufficiently advanced that
there should be some signal signature of
that but maybe it's coming i think the
deeper fundamental problem between us
and the ants is that we don't have a
common language it's not it's not the
interest it's that we don't even have a
common language
and so
the the alien civilizations don't even
know how to communicate like we humans
have
convinced ourselves we're special
because we developed the language you
talked about you talk about the
importance of language to intelligence
but it makes you wonder like how very
niche is that
like club that we've
like tribe we've created of language and
linguistic type of systems that are very
specific to our particular kinds of
brains and we share ideas together we're
all super excited that we can understand
the universe because we came up with
some notation
and math i wonder if there's some
totally other kinds of language that
communicates on a different time scale
with different very different mechanisms
in a space of information that's just
there's not
it's everything everything is lost in
translation yeah and it could well be
it's a look i mean i think part of the
reason i go toward the possibility
of the soul intelligence
is there's a certain kind of romantic
appeal
to looking out in the cosmos and it's
just quiet and it's just eternal silence
there's some there's something that
appeals to me at an emotional level that
way but yeah i mean um nobody
nobody knows and uh it's certainly um
conceivable
that where there's just a radical
mismatch between the kinds of things
that we are able to observe and
sensitive to
versus the kinds of structures that
permeate the universe in a manner that
simply we're unable to detect
you